la france une cocotte minute prête à
exploser c'est en tout cas la crainte de
l'exécutif et pour cause 18 mois après
le début de la pandémie les prix du gaz
et de l'électricité s'envolent plus 57 %
pour le gaz depuis le début de l'année
et 12% pour l'électricité en février
prochain traumatisé par la crise des
gilets jaunes qui avaient émergé pour
moins que ça à l'automne 2010 8
l'exécutif veut à tout prix éviter la
naissance d'un mouvement social de la
même ampleur
les français n'ont pas à prendre de
plein fouet cette augmentation des prix
du gaz nous assurerons notre rôle de
protection des français face à la
flambée des prix de l'énergie une
protection a minima et pas pour tous les
français pour les plus modestes
seulement une rallonge de 100 euros pour
les 5,8 millions de ménages est déjà
bénéficiaire du chèque énergie et parce
que c'était logiquement loin d'être
suffisant le premier ministre a annoncé
la création d'un bouclier tarifaire nous
mettons en place un bouclier tarifaire
concrètement pendant tout l'hiver
prochain le tarif du gaz ne dépassera
jamais le niveau d'octobre 2021 la
facture de chauffage des français
auraient dû augmenter de 30% cela
n'arrivera pas bloquer les prix après
augmentation jusqu'en avril 2029
autrement dit jusqu'à la prochaine
présidentielle et donc l'éventuelle
réélection d'emmanuel macron ces gros
pour être vrai et pourtant il y en a
marre de leur comme il y en a marre
depuis le début de l'année les prix
augmentent et c'est seulement maintenant
qu'il se réveille parce qu'on est à six
mois de l'élection présidentielle mais
ils nous prennent pour des imbéciles ou
quoi ces gens là les français n'ont pas
besoin de mesures est électoraliste mais
d'une baisse réelle et durable du prix
des énergies et de l'essence des
mesurettes électoralistes à en croire
donc une partie de l'opposition qui
estime que le gouvernement peut et doit
mieux faire avec 600 euros de plus sur
la facture de gaz les 200 euros annoncé
par le gouvernement n'est clairement pas
à la hauteur de la gravité de la
situation même son de cloche du côté des
syndicats le gouvernement doit d'abord
regarder des mesures ciblées pour les
ménages les plus modestes il faut sans
doute encore augmenter le chèque énergie
élargir ceux qui sont éligibles en
particulier aux franges des salariés qui
sont un peu au dessus des critères
actuels il y a déjà une forte précarité
énergétique dans notre pays beaucoup de
gens qui ne se chauffent pas où se
chauffent mal pendant l'hiver ça
provoque des situations terribles c'est
un problème majeur pour les ménages et
la perspective de reprise risque de se
heurter à la stagnation des salaires et
l'augmentation des factures pour faire
face à cette hausse du prix des énergies
l'association de consommateurs ufc que
choisir propose pour sa part une baisse
temporaire de la tva elle prend exemple
sur l'espagne où elle a été réduite
temporairement de 20 à 10% il y à des
mesures structurelles à prendre on ne
voit pas la légitimité d'une telle taxe
si on l'avait supprimée cela aurait des
gonfler la facture est à la hausse du
prix des énergies s'ajoutent les
réformes controversées une protestation
toujours aussi vive contre le passé ni
terre où la vaccination obligatoire pour
certains professionnels les déçus du
moment sont appelés à se mobiliser
partout en france ce 5 octobre un nouvel
appel à manifester qui témoigne de la
grogne sociale qui s'accentue et cela
dans tous les secteurs